can I be open with you Joe you're a
disgrace to the family your business is
a disaster
the - Nuria by Friday I'm closing this
stupid store you've never married and
you're sleeping around as if you just
discovered your willy I am prepared to
pay off all your debts of course I want
something in exchange for I want you to
move abroad you'll be living in Nova
Scotia you can't be cute me
hey I'm Cecilia I know your uncle you
told me that you might be coming oh you
should put an ad in the local weekly
newspaper yeah I'm in so really Althea
are gonna need the money what do you
want it to say yeah he look I fix
anything electrical this book
[Music]
what are you all doing here daddy placed
the healing oh I have arthritis my blood
sugar is off the chart yeah I'm like a
factory kidney stones man it seems to be
a bit of a mistake here I fix the
electrical thing just so in the end a
healer and I fix anywhere oh no I did I
didn't say that
we came because our daughter is very
sick I can't help the daughter doctors
say there's no cure I know this is my
gift to them house reconsider I'm gonna
try to cure me
how dare you come to this peaceful
community and try to scam these people
[Music]
you
gift which brought me back you're all
clinically insane through these people
these are your answers welcome to the
family you have the family giveth the
gift of healing like it or not you've
been chosen I don't want it you could
help so many people I don't want
anything to do with this people in this
town find miracles whether or not just
know I can't watch it die you made your
choice so I want it back you do I have
to convince that's would be the one you
don't believe them in your box came just
like in Caesarea live for me like
tomorrow's your last day son is no
denying you are healer
[Music]
you
[Music]
you